[Music]
so when you look at the really unique
bizarre things humans have come up with
ranging from cave paintings to snapchats
and everything in between probably the
most unique and universal thing we've
come up with is this religion business
where you talk about symbolic
metaphorical thinking essentially there
has been no culture on earth that has
not invented some form of what could be
termed meta magical thinking attributing
things that cannot be seen faith-based
belief systems things of that sort -
Universal 90 95 percent of people
believe in some sort of omnipotence
something rather out there every culture
out there has it
people have endlessly speculated about
the evolution of religiosity and at
least in terms of westernized religions
it makes perfect sense why they've
evolved because they're wonderful
mechanisms for reducing stress it is an
awful terrifying world out there where
bad things happen and we're all going to
die eventually and believing that there
is something someone responsible for it
at least give some stress-reducing
attributes built around understanding
causality if on top of that you believe
there is not only something out there
responsible for all of this but that
there is a larger purpose to it that's
another level of stress-reducing
explanation if then on top of it you
believe that individual out there is
benevolent even more so control and
predictability benevolent and listens to
human entreaties more elements of
control
benevolent listens to human entreaties
and prefers to listen to people like you
who look like you pray like you request
like you even more so they're just all
these levels of control predictability
they're stress-reducing
and what is infuriating to me as an
utter complete atheist is a very very
solid literature showing the health
benefits of religiosity independent of
you tend to get a social support of
community when you're religious you have
fewer lifestyle risk factors the mere
ability to perceive causality reason
benevolence benevolence especially for
people like me if I say the rate
contract combination of words and
fervently believe in it that's
wonderfully protective and there's
health benefits to it if it is a totally
heartless indifferent apathetic universe
out there you are far more at risk for
all the logical things which is to
conclude it is an utterly depressing
universe out there rates of depression
are much higher among atheists go figure
so in terms of that it makes perfect
sense why this is something that people
have come up with and rather than asking
why is it that 95 percent of humans come
up with some form of religiosity much
more biologically interesting question
to me is what's up with the 5% of
atheists who don't do that
[Music]